Example, you probably like what, what do you mean?
Make him feel good for spend him money.
Is that, that that's the only way you.
OK. Best friends. Let's jump right into this juicy girl. Video.
How to get a guy to spend money a.
The.
Up. Do that again.
Sorry, man. I, I really, it just got.
To me really good. Listen, can you stop interrupting this? Bootle Cardi B.
It does look like Cardi B.
Yo she.
Yo, yo, it's just that Cardi B's funnier, but she does.
Look like Cardi B. I met her. Yo she's making money moves. Yo,
she don't dance no more. Here's what I want to do.
I wanna infiltrate a feminist conference and one they're all sitting down ready
to like, hear the thing, speak. I want to just pop in this video.
And then she pops in.
<Laugh> I have to pick up the.
Money. Number one is test him. Why do you wanna test him?
Because you wanna make sure that he's a spending money on you type some guys,
you know, like to spend money on themselves and themselves only.
And if you bring it up to them, you know about spending money on you,
they're gonna flat out call you a gold Digger. This is my money. Da, da.
Yeah. Cause your body, your choice, his money, his.
Money. So lemme get this straight. Yeah.
You mad cuz you get with a man and you ask him to spend
money on you and he calls you a gold Digger.
That's what it is though.
That's like sleeping with people for money and then being surprised when they
call you AK worker. Listen, if you're a night Walker, be a night Walker.
Nobody cares. Walk the.
Nights be blade. That's a day. Walker.
Boo. You bugging. And before anyone gets mad to that,
why do y'all comments on these girls? On the fringe?
She's a YouTuber with like 800,000 subscribers.
And this is a very popular video she made. So don't be coming at me sideways.
Talk about fringe. This is not fringe.
There are dozens of tutorials like this on how to get a money to spend money.
And I'm.
Not mad at it. They're gonna come as you sideways.
They're not mad at it. Doesn't matter. I'm not mad at it. I'm not mad at it.
They're not money on me.
I'm I'm not at it. Can you go iron? I'm not mad at it.
Youre with I'm not mad it, but can.
So you wanna make sure that you test him? How do you test him? You throw,
you throw little things around like this. Okay.
So probably let's say you live by yourself. Oh my.
And you're on the phone with babe. I love doing this.
I hate when just do that grooming where they want some.
And so they start parting their hair so you can see their teeth. Listen.
Though. Listen though. Listen though. Listen, I'm about to go in though. Let me,
yo, let me talk though. Okay. So what try to do though? Listen, listen to me.
I'm about to get in. Okay?
Okay. So the first thing you wanna do is like, you know,
start a conversation like this. Like, oh my gosh,
it's the first of the month already.
Like I feel like I hardly ever have money to myself.
I'm always paying all these bills. Oh my God. So annoying.
Like when I've had money problems, the last thing I do shut the up.
With your money problems. That's the worst thing you gonna bring up on the date.
But then again, that's because of the agenda roles and stuff. That's.
What it is. And he, if he's as tight to spend money on you, he gonna be like,
bro, babe, that's crazy. Like, wait, how much do you pay? How much did you rent?
Oh, 1500. Right? Well I'm, I'm gonna, I'm gonna give you 1500.
When I see you later on today, if a guy like just out of the gate, out,
straight out the gate, volunteers to pay your bills, then you know, it's more,
it is more of that to come.
Okay man. Some people really live life on easy mode. Yes they do.
But some people really milk the out of it. Yeah.
They want a free ride for everything, but it can. That's crazy bro, bro,
this is going to me. This is going, yes. You say whatever you want. No,
I'm just looking for a, you going to me but live your life.
But if he turns around and says, yeah, that's crazy. Yo,
I hate being adult then like, I'm sorry to hear that. Like you got bills like,
like pretty much, you know, that's a cold word. That's a cold word. Um,
for like, I ain't helping you.
Cause why Woody? No, that's not.
That code word is if someone told me they were having financial problem,
like that sucks.
Cause I know I've been there too. Yeah. But you know what gratification is?
Gratification is when you struggle with life and then you overcome,
you don't have to struggle no more.
So there's no way that I'm gonna interrupt struggle and make it easy for them to
get past it. That's stupid to me. You think my friends come to me and be like,
life's hard, man. I can't pay my bills. Hoping that I pay their bills. No,
if you need my help with something, just ask me directly.
Don't do this indirect that you're emotionally manipulating me to help you.
That makes you trash. Listen.
If you actually manipulate someone to get what you want,
that's trashy and you can't ask whether it's compliments, whether it's food,
whether it's money, whether it's sex, whatever it is. If you manipulate,
take the money up. What if I did the same thing to get outta?
What does that make me? Okay girl. Yeah. Okay. You gotta have money props. Okay,
cool. Not problem. But you gonna have to do something. Me too. You got.
Money problems. Oh I ain't. Yeah. I.
Got Puy problem. That's it things that we don't have. That's it.
And so now you want to prop tape like, come on.
Now. Oh, now you going use my word. Aye.
I got you. I got, I got you're welcome.
Hey listen. I donate. She prorates.
We pro she teaches you how to pro.
I don't know why I'm telling you this. I helping your.
I don't got money like that. You know what I'm saying?
So that out the gate shows you. What kind of man you're dealing with.
Yo, if a girl says something like that,
she's telling you what kind of girl she is. Right? So just pay attention to the.
Sign. Parts your hair. <laugh>.
I started doing that. R and B singer bounce. Yeah. If a girl start,
do a like that. She's showing you what? A type of girl she,
You mean on the.
Floor. Now if he passed, then girl, you got yourself a good one.
You got yourself a low. I don't wanna say sugar. Daddy.
I don't wanna say sugar. Daddy. Cuz it make me look bad. So I'm gonna say,
you know, you got yourself, a man that is willing to provide.
Okay? Cause when I say how to get a guy to spend money on you,
I'm not talking about like, cuz I've never been a sugar baby. I never used guys.
You know, to be my sugar, daddy, this is your significant other like.
Shut up. I've never used that. I'm not like that. I'm not a sugar baby.
I'm a sugar infant. Plenty of people.
Marry their sugar daddies doesn't change the, my are, they stole the.
Sugar dead. That's one of my deal, breakings.
Like I can't be with a guy that thinks is a problem to spoil his girl.
That thinks a problem. Like every time I ask for something that there's.
A difference between spoiling a girl,
giving her like flowers and stuff like that.
Spoiling her and you manipulate.
This is Stu different things. Your girl and you know,
giving doing something nice for your significant other is not what you're
describing here.
You're manipulating mother to giving you exactly what you want them.
To pro men, women don't test your partners. Don't don't do tests.
It's not good. It's you's not good. You're using deceit to get information.
It's not, don't use.
The seat. Use your.
Words. It shouldn't be a problem. There's this quote that says,
if you're in a relationship and you're struggling, then CIS you're single.
And I couldn't agree with that post. Like, oh my God, I love that post so much.
Wow. We share.
Anything you wanna say.
Bro, just roll the clip.
I don't seen women in real relationships and they tell me like, oh my God,
like my car note, I'm backed up. And it's like, I, I used to be like,
why don't you just tell your boyfriend? Oh no, I don't wanna ask him.
Or I don't think he's gonna give it to me since are you kidding me?
You're freaking single. My mom always taught me that like, you know,
I make my own money and as women, we should make our own money,
but we should be able to have men to like, you know the times get hard.
Like I babe, here you go, babe, you need a hundred dollars.
You need a hundred dollars. Here you go. Here's doing 20 here.
Man. Why do you throw that money at you? Like you were a stripper, yo.
Number two is,
go on dates that are nearby shopping sensors.
What?
Going out with this guy. And when he, he asked me one time where you wanna go?
And I said, yeah, I wanna go to this. You know, see for restaurant whatever.
And cuz I knew that it was across the street from like the mall mm-hmm
<affirmative>. So after we ate and he said, what you wanna do after? Just like,
I just, like I thought he would say, and I was like, oh I, you know,
the mall is up the block.
We could walk around the, he said right, let's walk around the mall.
And then as we were walking around the mall, he's like, you want anything?
Chiche I'm car, stop something. I want this, I want this.
And matter of fact, you not gonna forever 21. Let's go.
So let's go to the Louis store real quick. It's something that I want. Okay.
And, and lo and behold girl,
he took me shopping and I really, really enjoyed that.
Like that made me look at him differently. Like, oh, like you husband material,
you know what I'm saying?
She probably didn't even stay with this too. No, of course not. I.
Always look at every guy I date as, mm.
Can he be like my husband and stuff like that? Cuz you know,
that's one of the things I look for in a husband,
like I feel like stability is so sexy.
What you're asking for is not stability. What you're asking for is luxury.
It's not the same thing.
Stability is a nine to five with a solid pension plan and guaranteed
benefits. What you're looking for at the Louis store is not stability. Poo.
All right. It's luxury.
You want someone to feed your ego cuz you can't stop shopping like loser.
Cause you don't.
Have the talent to do it yourself.
Part of me, maybe,
also slightly feels bad for cause she's inherited this from her mother.
So she taught like, you know,
some people learn the value system from their parents. Yeah.
And they learn how affection is supposed to look like. Yeah.
Her mom taught her that men buy you stuff. That's sad too.
But if, if it gets edited, it's not something that we came up to the conclusion.
That's what she actually said in the video. So.
You do number two, you go on a date.
That's about shopping centers to see if he spends money on you.
You got you a winner. If he don't, that's the last date you hear me?
That's the last date. He's cheap. He's cheap. He's gonna sit back on. You,
spend your money and turn him on and ask you for your money. He's.
Cheap. He's gonna let you spend your money.
And then after that it's gonna turn around and ask you for your money.
Ain't that? What you doing? So if he is cheap, he's gonna let you,
he is gonna be what you're doing.
Right now. Yeah. But a man's supposed to be a man. That's how.
Those type of guys work. Okay. <laugh> all right.
So let's move on to tip number three. How to get a guy to spend money on you.
Number three is make him feel good for spending money on you.
Exact. I said exactly. Example. You probably like what, what do you mean?
Make him feel good for spending your money on?
That's the only way
I hope you do. If he buy you Louisana and you still not sucking. We got a prom.
Boom don't gimme no words. Use mouth for something else. Make him feel special.
Make him make him profit.
Okay. At least that's at least that's a cycle of.
Life. If you make a guy feel good for spending money on you, SIS,
he's gonna spend more money on you because you make him feel good about it.
So example is like, let's say he bought, he took you shopping like, oh my God,
thank you baby. Like, I really, he appreciated like,
you're so different from the other dudes. I date, you know what I'm saying?
But don't overdo it. You know? Cuz guys can tell when you're being fake,
you know, like give him my kiss. Like babe, thank you so much.
You know what I'm saying? Like, I love you. Like, and he's gonna, you know,
he's gonna be like, or you know, just, just show appreciation.
She's a cheap hope she got the goods and she's still didn't offer the
goods. Ew.
And I remember there's a couple people who got mad at me. I,
but you used a proto in the past, at least the prostitute delivered.
I respect that. She said 50 euros an hour. I said, yes,
ma'am let's prostitute. And I slammed that money on the table and we.
Pro, but that was, that was a clear transaction. Yeah. The people that are
mad at this and they're saying like, oh you use this, you use that. And listen,
that was a on, that was a honest transaction. I give you money.
Provided the entertainment. What? The.
Last thing you wanna do is for even just in general in life,
somebody does something for you.
I feel like it's your duty to go out your way to make them feel good and make
them feel like it was the right decision to help you.
Nobody ever wanna feel used. And did.
You did the audacity?
Did you say nobody,
everyone to feel you and then you pull all this game to have
all this money yet. Nobody wants to fill you.
This. YouTube is not good for my mental.
Health. You have to take breaks.
You can't always just listen to this all the time. The.
Point of this video is that we don't wanna use our man, but we just want,
this is for the ladies that that love to be spoiled. Like me. That's my.
That's my love language.
Well, you know like, listen, it's just the way I was raised.
Like I felt like you don't love me unless you slap me. You know what I'm saying?
That's my love language. No, she was born into dysfunction.
You gotta sort some out. This. Not healthy. It's my love language.
It's my love language. So.
Make it him feel good. You know what I'm saying? Make him feel good. Tell,
thank you. Um, I don't wanna say sleep with him and put your hand,
put your hand point time, go to work. You know what I'm saying?
Cause that's like, you know like pro.
We're good. We're good set. Sit. Set it down. We're good. We're done down.
We're good bro.
We're done.
Don't you dare salt pro you are not a half of what a pro is.
They're.
Doing honest work. They know what the they're doing. It's this for that.
And that's it. You try to pass it. outta here. Get all your.
Take all your. Get.
The out. See the thing is prostitutes.
Operate on pusy you operate on implied. Pusy right.
Yo, you are selling them.
The Oasis in the desert prostitutes are selling on Nile
boo. We know it exists. We go get it. We know where to find it on the map.
Yours keep walking the desert. Maybe you gonna find me. Nah, nah,
I ain't messing with that. No, I'm thirsty. I'm thirsty. I brought the camels.
Let's drink. Wow. Let's.
Go. So number four, this is very important. If you don't, if you,
if you do this too much, you're not gonna get not a nothing, not a Don,
not a coin at a quarter.
Number four is don't close his money or he will catch on
and cut you off. Now I'm sad to say, but I,
I know this from experience. <laugh>.
You hear what she said?
Don't overdo it or he will catch on catch on to what?
It sounds like a scheme.
You literally sound like you've done something wrong and you know, it's wrong.
He's going to catch on to what you're doing. Listen to the words deceiving.
You know what it is. He knows. She.
Knows don't pretend. Otherwise she knows.
She put the holes and knows. She knows.
But I remember like this guy, like taking,
shopping all the time and literally like every week we would just go shopping
and then one day he was just like, oh I gotta, but you know,
the thing is we were in together and that he just like liked me. And like,
he just used to just take shopping. Like that's a.
Friend zone. That's a simple zone, simple.
Zone. Fi zone is the basement of the friend zone.
It almost sounds like we're saying Simpson. No SI zone zone. Yo Simpson zone.
Sounds like a good rapper name though. Yeah.
SIM zone SI zone SIM zone Simpson zone. Jim Jones. Jim Jones.
We stay fly NOLA.
You know this Simpson.
<Laugh>.
Do this little old trick. That's the oldest in the bug where it works.
Pull out your wallet first and act as if you're going to pay.
The first word of that was pretend it the Oaks she,
she put the whole in Oaks. Wow.
That's what you move after Dodge in the dating.
Life. No, no. I've never been with someone like that. God.
I feel like I would weed out a scandalous person like this. Also.
I don't come across as a type to spend a lot of money on people.
I'll pay for a first date. If I ask someone out and I have no problem,
you don't.
Even spend a lot of money on you. You.
Yeah. That's true. You.
You, you do the essential. You understand what I'm saying? You do the essential.
So I don't see you now when I was saying that, of course,
I don't see you with a brother like that. You would cut that girl off.
Real quick. Like it's not part of my values.
My values don't lie in spending money. That's not how I derive joy or pleasure.
And life doesn't mean that I won't spend money. You know,
we go out to a restaurant I'm paying, I'll take you somewhere.
I don't mind that. That's not the problem. I'll pay for an experience like that.
I don't mind. That's not hold on. Let me finish.
But what I'm trying to say is like, when it comes to materialistic stuff,
I would never be with someone like that. Because the way I structure my values,
it's not something that's important to me. It doesn't matter what I buy.
I'll never feel good or better.
So to be with someone who would just because they bought like a new pair of
clothing, it wouldn't interest me to me. That's a poor value system. What?
You're only happy if you're spending money.
So what happens if we find hard times or you don't want to be with no broken,
of course, I'm not gonna be with you.
I wanna be with someone I can struggle with.
I want be with someone I can thrive with.
I want to be with someone who can go through ups and downs.
If you're only here because I can spend a thousand dollars on you a week,
you're trash, you're garbage. I would never even socialize.
You wouldn't even be in my circle of friends.
You wouldn't even wanna be someone I wanna talk to. That's how I feel.
Cuz you're low quality human to me. That's it. And it's okay if you are,
but we don't have to socialize.
Anyone manipulate people like this you're trash.
You said that she's she knows she's bad too. Just by the language.
Just by language, don't overdo it or he's gonna catch on catch what?
Catch on to what? I've never hit someone,
something like that from someone of my partners that said,
I don't want her to catch on to what I'm doing. What? I don't know.
This is initially like we're laughing at her. Then it became cringy.
And then it just became like, oh no, you are a manipulative bad person.
I take it back. I take back every time I called her or hold no,
this person is not that she's some other evil.
She's a Le someone who latches onto you sucks. You dry or sucks,
whatever she can out of you. And then leaves. If I in PAA that suck.
No succubus delivers the goods. Oh yeah. I know.
Cause I've had plenty of succubus fantasies. Oh wow. Yeah.
I play a lot of fantasy games and they come and look sexy and fake. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Yeah. And they're all like, they're all like, yeah.
For a night of pleasure. I just want some of your life force. And I was like,
that sounds like every day sex to me. <laugh> you?
That's why unanimously <laugh> but the vampires
depends on hot. They are. Nah, they're gonna leave you dry like that. Well,
I mean, some of them are very modest vampires. I know.
Cause I interact with them. Okay.
And they just take a little bit of blood enough because they don't want to,
you know, but the bad ones though, it doesn't matter.
I play a lot of fantasy games. Now I can see that. Yeah. Yeah.
I've thought about it too. Some vampire. Yeah.
I've had warm but cold cold with you. I love my warm chicken, but cold meats.
Cold cuts. <laugh> I I've been to subway. My.
I've been to subway. My. You beat eating fresh. <laugh>
vampire eat fresh,
man. I'm just saying, just say, just say, you know what it is.
So that's how I feel about this. She yeah, just have some pride guys.
I have some pride learn to do things on your own.
I'm not saying you can't ask for help from time to time.
That's not thing what she was talking about with some other.
I've definitely helped people out financially when they were in need that.
That's not a problem's what about this is some other y'all this is some other
y'all yeah.
I can't believe from what you guys are feeling dealing with this.
It's out there. You understand what I'm saying? It's out there.
Is she the equivalent of boy? Yes.
Like you know how boy manipulates you to get outta you? That's a,
she manipulates men to get money out of it. See, the thing.
That happened is that a boy is gonna use love to get a.
Girl is gonna get you to get.
Materialistic. Well, there you go.
So that's pretty much all we got for today's video listener.
What you guys thinking? The comments below we get to.
Subscribe to on.